from an art Heist gone horribly wrong to
the most messed up body horror nightmare
in years these are the best thrillers
you already missed this year
Gerard Butler's action thriller plane
got buried early in 2023 due to little
marketing and no momentum heading into
its January release that's a shame
because it's honestly one of the actors
is best this action-packed adventure
follows pilot Brody Torrance as he's
forced to crash land a plane into a
remote island whereas passengers are
taken hostage by a local Rebel faction
with the help of one of his writers a
former Soldier accused of murder Brody
must rescue his passengers and help them
get off the island and I'm telling you
that the way home is on this plane
I've got you this far I just need to
trust me this one more bit plain
features one of the most harrowing Crash
Landing sequences you'll see in a movie
and it perfectly sets the tone for the
incredibly tense fights that follow all
the great suspense and strong Chemistry
Between Butler and actor Mike Coulter
helped lead the film to an undeniably
epic firefight finale sure Butler's
action thriller flicks have been a
little one note in the past but despite
this simple title plane is far from
generic providing viewers with the kind
of Thrill Ride the audiences are always
searching for
anyone that's seen director Brandon
cronenberg's previous films antiviral
and possessor know that he's a modern
master of sickeningly Twisted Thrills
much like his father David the younger
cronenberg's latest project infinity
pool takes viewers on a luxury vacation
that takes a Sinister turn struggling
writer James played by Alexander
Skarsgard gets the death penalty when he
accidentally kills a man with his car
he's given a bizarre proposition though
for a fee James will be cloned and the
Clone will be executed in his place it's
a choice that continues to haunt him as
he descends into a depraved criminal
underworld that pushes him to his limits
with infinity pool Cronenberg once again
manages to elicit plenty of icks from
the audience there are moments that'll
leave viewers tense and Disturbed
especially when Mia goth's performance
and that signature Cronenberg body
horror are involved infinity pool may
have slipped past wider audiences but
that doesn't mean that it's incredible
crime Thrills and gripping [__] should
be ignored maybe think of it as a gift
back in 2018 Sony screen gems delivered
a breakout hit with search Inc in which
John Cho gives an unforgettably gripping
performance through some Stellar webcam
Thrills and a twisty mystery it's
possible many fans of the first film
don't know that an equally great sequel
hit theaters in 2023 largely because
it's called missing rather than
searching too and it was buried by
January release like searching missing
utilizes its web-based premise and smart
ways as young June uncovers disturbing
truths about her family after her mother
disappears missing is an unbelievable
Thrill Ride that's guaranteed to leave
viewers shocked by its unexpected turns
and wild twists storm reads lead
performance perfectly leads audiences
through all the chilling discoveries
June makes keeping viewers hooked right
up until the supremely tense and
explosive finale given how popular
searching was when it hit it's baffling
that missing was just thrown under the
rug by Sony that doesn't mean that this
is a movie worth forgetting about though
far from it whether he's playing good
Lighthouse Keeper the Green Goblin or
Jesus Christ himself Willem Dafoe never
fails to turn in a standout performance
and that definitely applies for 2023's
inside still fans of the actor may have
missed the heist turned survival flick
that stars Defoe alongside pretty much
no one else Defoe fly solo as Nemo an
art Thief whose latest job goes terribly
wrong after security system malfunction
leaves him trapped inside a luxury
apartment while a penthouse suite might
not seem like such a terrible place to
get stuck it quickly becomes a living
hell his Escape options are severely
limited and the security system
constantly fluctuates the apartment's
temperature between sweltering heat and
frigid coals as Nemo's situation
continues to grow dire his sanity starts
to slip and that's when defoe's
performance truly captivates
inside provides some good survival
Thrills and inventive moments that'll
give viewers hooked from the start but
it's defoe's one-man show that'll really
leave an impact Nemo slowed descent into
madness and disjointed reality makes for
our harrowing watch one that will keep
you guessing up until the very end
inside got completely overshadowed by
Shazam Fury of the Gods when it hit
theaters but that doesn't mean that
audiences should miss out on its
uniquely intriguing premise and
performance
not every Thriller needs to provide
painful moments or chilling turns to be
a highly engaging ride and Guy Richie is
criminally underseen operation Fortune
ruse deguerre is proof this star-studded
adventure follows a team of spies as
they recruit a movie star in an effort
to stop an evil billionaire arms dealer
operation Fortune is essentially
Richie's take on a James Bond spy
adventure and it makes for a hilariously
fun time Richie's signature style of
Comedy Works perfectly in creating some
very funny and engaging moments from the
highly talented cast which includes
Jason Statham Aubry Plaza Josh Hartnett
Hugh Grant and Carrie Elwes the action
is fast and Fierce and there's no
shortage of wild gun fights and
thrilling chases based on the film's
poor box office performance operation
Fortune clearly wasn't on a lot of
Radars when it hit theaters but better
late than ever when it comes to watching
this highly entertaining romp
since the pandemic delayed the release
of operation Fortune two guy Richie
films ended up coming out in the first
half of 2023. the second one was the
Covenant which made it to theaters in
the U.S just a month and a half after
the director's previous effort and while
it's also a quality watch it couldn't be
more different in tone the Covenant is
set during the war in Afghanistan and
stars Jake Gyllenhaal and dar Salim
Sergeant John Kinley and his Afghan
interpreter Ahmed help innocent people
survive against the taliban's growing
Shadow but when ahmed's family becomes
threatened Kinley must take matters into
his own hands along with Gyllenhaal and
Saleem delivering Great Performances
Richie helmed some incredibly
suspenseful firefights that are bound to
leave viewers hanging on the edge of
their seats throughout all the close
calls and unsettling suspense the entire
last Act is a true fight for survival
which makes for a very satisfying and
cathartic conclusion the Covenant
arguably got overshadowed by the
breakout success of Evil Dead rise but
that simply means that Richie has a
killer double major full of amazing
lesser-known Thrills waiting for people
to experience
when it first debuted critics praised
Daniel goldhabber's activist Thriller
how to blow up a pipeline for its solid
script and impressive ensemble cast
despite its instantly compelling title
though the reverse Heist flick didn't
gain much popularity in mainstream
circles inspired by author Andreas mom's
2021 book of the same name how to blow
up a pipeline follows eight young people
as they plot to destroy oil
infrastructure in West Texas the film's
environmentalist message and
philosophical conundrums are front and
center after all our heroes never quite
decide whether what they're doing counts
as terrorism or not American Empire
calls us terrorists and we're doing
something right from a narrative
perspective the movie's most significant
achievement is its ability to get
viewers invested in the individual
stories of all eight members over its
100 minute run time things only become
more nerve-shredding as the group goes
deeper into crafting their plan the
stakes ratchet up and things start to go
horribly wrong how to blow up a pipeline
is full of shockingly explosive moments
and gripping turns that'll leave viewers
stunned
it's no surprise that an international
Thriller on Netflix can end up being
overlooked with so much content on the
service it's easy for something to get
lost in the shuffle of course that
doesn't mean that subscribers should
miss out on killbox soon and Incredibly
fun South Korean Thriller Gil box soon
is both an assassin and a single mom
whose life and Flawless success rate on
the job are put into Jeopardy when she
finds herself in a kill or be killed
conflict director sung young bian shows
some great prowess in crafting thrilling
and engaging action sequences that
aren't afraid to spill some blood
keeping viewers hooked on every punch in
slash whether it's through brutal
hand-to-hand combat or with a variety of
weapons the titular assassin absolutely
makes her mark on her foes and the
audience in the process kill box soon
features a great cast of characters with
distinct personalities and a slow
growing conflict that boils over into a
shocking finale it's a shame that great
movies like kill box soon can easily be
missed so you should definitely add it
to your watch list
since it was also dropped onto Netflix
without much fanfare fans of the BBC One
show Luther might not realize that a
film continuation called the Fallen Sun
hit the streaming service in early March
the film sees Idris Elba reprise his
role as disgrace detective John Luther
as he tries to right the wrongs of his
past and capture the serial killer who
continues to haunt him Alba returning to
this role will definitely feel
satisfying for fans but the movie is
also an excellent Gateway for newcomers
to learn about one of the actors most
iconic roles the Fallen sun is a very
solid serial killer hunt with twists and
turns that'll keep you guessing at how
things will end if Idris Elba wasn't
enough of a draw the Fallen Sun Also
features great supporting performances
from Andy Circus and Cynthia Arriva
there is really a moment to catch your
breath and you never truly know when
things are about to get brutal whether
you're a long time Luther fan or someone
looking to get a taste for what it's all
about the Fallen sun is a Thriller worth
checking out
[Music]